both US Democratic presidential election
debate took place on Tuesday night and
even the moderator struggled to hide a
support for some candidates
mr. vice president president Trump has
falsely accused your son of doing
something wrong while serving on a
company board in Ukraine I want to point
out there's no evidence of wrongdoing by
either one of you look my son did
nothing wrong I did nothing wrong I
carried out the policy of the United
States government in rooting out
corruption in in Ukraine and it seems
it's not only those debates where Biden
is enjoying exceptional support the
newly released report by news website
the gray zone claims a senior fellow at
the Atlantic Council think-tank a vocal
supporter of Biden isn't that impartial
at all it says Michael carpenter works
for a firm allegedly funded by a company
Biden's son used to run Biden supported
the fight against corruption and
advocated increased scrutiny of
wrongdoing including urging an
investigation of Burr yzma vice
president biden in 2014-2015 after after
the revolution of dignity in Ukraine was
pushing for Ukrainian reformers to be
able to fight corruption and the report
suggests mr. carpenter is intentionally
not referring to his Atlantic Council
fellowship with a think-tank allegedly
taking as much as $250,000 a year from
Boris Morel where Joe Biden's son was on
the board of directors we spoke to the
author of the report max Blumenthal you
have a clear connection here between
Biden's campaign and a think tank that
is whitewashing Burr yzma's reputation
in Washington the Atlantic Council the
same think-tank that is hosted Joe Biden
over the years especially when he was
vice president as a keynote speaker at
its galas and various conferences but
the partnership between Burr yzma and
the Atlantic Council is picking up where
hunter Biden left off
it's a classic pay-for-play operation
that's not only welcomed in Washington
but invited
Hunter Biden joined the board of
Ukraine's Bruce Makassar in 2013 and
quickly became embroiled in a corruption
investigation that was soon closed over
lack of evidence Donald Trump over has
accused his father Joe Biden of
improperly leveraging his role as vice
president and having a hand in outing
the prosecutor who was investigating the
case the author of the reporter max
Blumenthal again says this scandal would
definitely affect Biden as a
presidential candidate it's really
arrogant for Joe Biden and for his
political operation to have gone into
this presidential race thinking this
wouldn't be an issue and it shows how
normalized these kinds of dirty deals
and pay-for-play arrangements are in
Washington Biden really has no coherent
or credible response to it except to say
look at Trump he's worse than I am
it's shocking to me that US media uses
the Atlantic Council as a source of
credible expertise when essentially what
it is is a lobbying operation for
repressive foreign governments the arms
industry the US military NATO and
Western aligned oligarchs
you